a Shadowhunters fans thank you so much
for joining us on ET i'm leanna Galera
and I'm joined right now by the one and
only Katherine McNamara how you doing
girl I'm doing it's a lot to process
it's not very interesting 24 hours but
I'm here and I'm happy I'm so glad that
you're here and for all you
Shadowhunters fans I don't know how
you're doing after that two and a half
hour finale but start telling us right
now I will be taking your questions in
comments and passing them along to Kat
but I love the fact that you're coming
in right now your voice is a little
hoarse how was it watching the series
finale of Shadowhunters with your
co-stars it was the only way to do it to
be honest
truly it was the best way to kind of
give a last hurrah a hail and farewell
to the show that we've all cared so much
about for so many years I mean the show
has quite literally been my entire life
since I was 19 years old and that it's
such an influential period of your life
given that now I'm in my mid-20s and and
it was something I've realized is it's
so much about the people you're
surrounded by and the environment you're
in that shapes who you become in those
years and I just feel so lucky to have
been surrounded by such incredible
people in that time it has been three
seasons yeah four years of your life
fifty-five episodes and it culminated in
a two and a half hour series finale
let's talk about this when you
originally read the script for the first
time what was your initial reaction so
my initial reaction it's actually very
funny
I instantly connected with the character
yeah I just knew there are certain roles
that you know from my mindset an actor's
job is to audition yeah and you go to
that room for your 10 minutes and you
leave and you leave it there but there
are certain roles that you read and you
go no this one's mine and I'm not gonna
take no for an answer that was Clary for
me funnily enough when I read the script
I went G Jace really reminds me of Tom
Sherwood because Tom and I were friends
and I read the characters like man he
would kill this and then a couple weeks
later I saw that he was cast and then
even more so I was like alright this is
it yeah this is my gettin this I'm gonna
make this happen I'm gonna fight hard
and I did and here we are and now here
we are the series finale was so
thrilling thank you so many different
things happened let's kick it off first
of all with the fact that Clary killed
Jonathan and she did it in such an
interesting way she created the special
rune yes I helped him to that yeah yeah
yeah almost kindness yeah no but it but
in essence what it is is it's a little
bit of an homage to the books because in
the book she does a very similar she
stabs him and look but she does a very
similar thing in that she blitter AIT's
all of the demonic nature from him and
in doing so what that in essence does is
it kills him yeah because there isn't
and he was made demonic in utero and so
he doesn't even have enough human or
enough Nephilim in him to survive which
is sort of the tragedy of Jonathan you
see at the last second you see his hair
turn red you see all of this yeah and
when Luke this is the last scene
obviously that Luke Bane's and I shot
together who is just one of my favorite
yeah I came around the corner of that
car during rehearsal and we both
instantly just started crying because we
didn't want this journey to be over and
and I just remember coming around the
corner clean look at you and your
demoness I'm just so proud of majestic
with the whole thing and uh he'd really
finally come in today did you guys have
to wear blackout contacts
no that was all CGI effects VFX yeah
they are just dream boats with
everything they've done for our show
they've created the magic of the world
they've created all of the things that
we'd see as tennis balls and you know
stunt guys in in little suits on set
with sticks in their hands they make it
magical and they make it wonderful but
you know back to the hole
Jonathan Clary relationship Jonathan is
my favorite character from the books and
getting to work with two of my favorite
human beings with will tutor with Luke
Bane's
on a relationship that's my favorite one
or one of my favorite sort of weird
dichotomous relationships on the show it
was like I was a kid in a candy store
you are our big mouth Malick shipper I
am well one Nikola and I think the
captains
the mallet I have to say Malek ship I
will I would be one of your skippers I
got excited
um the Malik wedding be still our
beating hearts you know when you walked
into set and you saw the extravagant
nature of it all what was your initial
reaction so I was there training with
one of our boxing coaches that morning
so I snuck in to set to look at it
before anyone else is there when they
were still building it and my I was
speechless
it took my breath away I mean leave it
to Magnus Bane to create the most
beautiful wedding imaginable mat Z is
the flower girl all perfect
oh and that kids and sort of if you look
like Clary and Isabel and Maris's dress
and and Ariana's dress they're all kind
of coordinated Matz's dress if you look
at it it was kind of in our minds that
he had picked out dresses for all of the
special people in his life as well and
Caterina says Wow it's me yeah so when
you put it all together it came to such
a cohesive unit but I don't think anyone
had to try to cry during the wedding I
think just because it had become such a
it was such a full-circle element for
all of us with the Malick wedding season
1 and you know I was sitting next to
Alberto and both weddings and it's it
just came full circle for everyone and
yeah it was very touching yeah
at the Malak wedding is when we really
got to see that Clary was getting her
Shadowhunter status stripped away from
her her runes were disappearing and I
did not want to believe that it was
actually all going to happen yeah and
then we see that final dance with you
and Jace we see the letter and then we
see that it's all gone that was our last
day on set really that was our last
shooting day it was all of them Alec
wedding reception with the dance and
with all those scenes with me and
Alberto and and me and Nicola and me and
Dom actually that scene with Dom was the
last scene we shot for the show and I
couldn't have asked for a better way to
wrap it all up those were the scenes
that from the moment I read the script I
couldn't get through them without crying
because Todd and Darrin did such a
beautiful job of culminating not only
everything that these characters
relationships encompassed but also each
of us as human beings and
as co-workers and family and whatever
you want to call us because it's far
beyond that so that made that day so
special and it was more fun to work for
the emotion because it was there yeah so
it nots actually people have often asked
me what my favorite clay scene is when
my favorite clay scene is from the
finale and it's that one when we're
dancing right there before I walk away
because you'd never see Clary professor
love ya even in the books and in the
books and in the show that's the one
moment that she does and that speech is
taken directly from the books as well
and so it brought everything full circle
with Jason Clarion and it was just a
beautiful moment for me and then we had
the one-year time jump yes and then we
had the one-year time to introduce yes
we are introduced to a brand new Cleary
and we got to see that she is fully in
her artistic abilities now yeah and they
see each other and she recognizes him
mm-hmm
talk to me about the scene so this scene
it's very interesting because there's
there have been so many questions posed
throughout the series of what what would
Clary have been like had she never found
the shadow world what would have
happened to her life if she'd gone at
the Brooklyn Academy of Art and and made
it through and done gone that route
instead and this is sort of the essence
of what that would have been this is the
Clary that would have been and so we
really wanted to take a moment and
depart as much as we could from the
shadow world yeah
with her look with her hair with the way
she dresses and with everything about
her and yet there's something about her
connection with Jace yeah there is
something about I mean that's what
started the series off when they bumped
into each other in the alley outside
pandemonium she has the sight she can
see through the glamour and always has
been able to and always will be able to
that's that connection with Jace that
goes beyond any Angelics fight it goes
beyond anything and that kind of brings
everything full circle and leaves for
sort of the open ending of what could
happen next in your mind what could
happen next
see what I love about the last scene is
that I didn't even know when we were
shooting it but they caught certain
little things that'll smirks and
glimmers in the eyes between me and Dom
and it leaves it open kind of for the
potential did she remember all along
yeah did she remember in that moment
when she saw Jays yeah or is she about
to remember is it all gonna come
flooding back we don't know and we may
never know but that's the best thing
about the shadow fam is that they love
to discuss and deliberate and so I leave
it to you we don't know they don't know
what do you think I think there are
certain things in your subconscious as a
as a being of whatever sort Nephilim or
human or otherwise you know things you
have instincts there's something that
and when you click with a person that
connection goes beyond anything and I
think that's essentially what it is is
these two people are connected yeah and
they're drawn to each other and they
always will be no matter what and so
whether or not she remembers she will
come to learn about the shadow world one
way or another because they're meant to
be mm-hmm I love that you had mentioned
the scene from the pilot where Clary saw
Jace mm-hmm outside of pandemonium
because we have that scene for you oh
and what I want to do is I want you to
watch that scene right now and tell us
everything you remember about filming it
any behind the scenes tidbits so we will
go ahead and let that moment roll for
sure
so this one this scene was actually shot
in the soundstage this particular one so
I don't think we actually shot that one
on the patient we had to reshoot it
later on rocks we had so much fun but
okay now this cuts this was the show it
again you can see me yeah it's kind of
the point that you obviously you didn't
see me you have to shut
how can I not know who you are is that
lyin seriously ever worked for you it's
so funny to see these characters like
this because you're at Chase who's
became so committed yeah so wonderfully
monogamous by the end of the show who
was it the beginning you really imagine
it's great up top
know the guy right there running into
the club there's just nobody there
why are you talking about because
seriously don't see him no did you stop
making me feel insane I think that way
Clary what was in your latte well let's
run after skits
so now you're making ID sign on your
18th birthday cuz that's such a - oh
yeah I have a little live a little
friend you see the hot tattooed man run
into the bar that nobody else can see
but only you can yes you chase after
half that followed the you it's like a
unicorn you have to follow the unicorn
sure no it's that's so amazing to see
and I remember we had Mike G directing
that episode so it became such a sense
of play for all of us we were still
discovering what the world was we were
still discovering these characters and
their relationships and and kind of the
essence of what the show would be but
that really did set us off on a
beautiful path for the rest of the
series to have that moment of play
because we did become so close
personally that it puts you at ease
immediately and lets you kind of explore
these characters in a new way we are
going to start diving into fan questions
yes let's do it
I'm here for you this is shadow fan
therapy we're gonna kick off with a
special fan question from our friend
abnormally Adam hi babe we love you Adam
yeah and Adam wants to know so he
watched the finale last night he was
speechless
I watched your reaction already I woke
up this morning was the first thing I
did so thank you
okay so Adam wants to know seeing how
far Clary has come since the first
season did you feel like she came full
circle at the end of the series was
there anything you would have liked to
see and happen in the finale I mean
there's so much I would have loved to
have seen happen in the finale but I I
really do credit Todd and Darrin with
doing such an amazing job of wrapping
everything up
as much as we possibly could in the time
that we had I think if there's anything
more I would have liked to see it would
have been nice to see an extra moment of
Clary having come into her home with the
shadow what our idea was for season four
is to take her full-on military soldier
mentis Eve and that would be her way of
redeeming herself for all of the things
that she did as as dark Clary all of the
kind of transgressions and all the
mistakes she's made she was gonna go
full tilt almost in the vein of Alec's
season one interesting and go kind of
that direction so I would have loved to
have seen that and explored that because
I had so many plans but for this
situation what it was I thought having
that ending is really lovely yeah we
were getting in so many of your fan
comments right now let's kick us off
Shelby Hoskins said why didn't Clary
tell Jace that she was leaving in person
he wouldn't have let her go you know
this this is why and that's why those
scenes were so hard yeah II to do with
the scene with Alberto and the scene
with Dom at the very end because I
couldn't I had to keep the emotion at
bay yeah without you know letting what I
was actually I think fall out of my
eyeballs but that's the thing because
either one of them would not have let
her leave yeah they would have said no
we're gonna find a way to fix this
there's a way around this
when Clary knows full well that there
isn't and she made the choice in full
awareness to take care of Jonathon yeah
knowing that it was going to cost her
everything okay we've got some really
good ones right now Sabrina Gomez says
did you cry while losing your runes
because you had to or because those were
real tears a little bit of both yeah I
have to say it was very funny the last
couple days on set putting on our runes
every morning became such a routine yeah
and it became kind of part of the
transformation into the character and
those last few days I didn't get to put
all my runes on and there were days
where we could sit there and take them
off in the middle of scenes and I it was
weird
it felt like a piece of me had been
taken away and it still does sometimes
I'm looking back at old pictures covered
in ruin
I miss them and it's just it's it's
funny having something on your skin for
so long it becomes a part of you and
that's very true for the finale which is
why I think it was written so
beautifully is because they hit all of
the points that all of us couldn't put
into words and they did it so
beautifully to make sure that we did
justice and honor this world that we all
created I'm not sure if you are a tattoo
person or a tattoo fan but would you get
a Shadowhunter tattoo I have I do and
it's actually it's it's Dom Sherman's
fault I'll tell about but I'm so
thankful for it and this is honestly
what I love about being Big Brother by
the shadow fan because they have kind of
pushed me outside my comfort zone in
ways that I never thought I would but I
learned so much and I grew so much and I
needed the little bit of corrupting that
baby because they're just the most
wonderful wonderful people but yeah so
we had a lot of us ended up getting the
angelic rune for season one amazing and
then for each season I've gotten another
tattoo you can kind of see it there's
many pictures on the internet
yeah of Maya yes of these tattoos it's
kind of for me has been a way to mark
each season picking each rune for
different reasons and moving forward
okay so if Kat caucus wants to know what
do you like the most about Clary what I
love the most about her is that she's
not perfect
yeah she's half angel yes but she's also
half human and she has the best of
intentions and she will be the person
who always has hope and who always wants
to do the right thing but sometimes
she's selfish and sometimes she doesn't
understand the consequences and she
makes mistakes and she makes rash
decisions without thinking things
through and falls on her face half the
time literally and figuratively Pollachi
outtakes mm-hmm but ultimately what that
does is it creates a character that is
relatable and as human and I have
learned so much from Clary about how
it's you know it's okay to not be
perfect it's okay to to make these
mistakes as long as you can pick
yourself back up
who Morganville at 94 wants to know what
is your favorite Clary quote there's so
many good ones there are so many good
ones my favorite Clary quote I have to
say when it comes from my favorite scene
just because it was a book quote and
because it was such a moment the first
one that comes to my head is Clary
speech - Jace when they're dancing at
the Malick wedding just because there's
something so beautiful about the way she
says every single cell in my body loves
you and because of how I don't maybe it
makes me a science nerd but the way it
works it's so beautifully it's such a
beautiful metaphor for what their love
is and I just I love that moment my one
almost caveat about the scene that
you're talking about between Jace and
Clary is as she's walking out she says I
need to get some air and she's clearly
upset she's clearly crying and she walks
out my first thought was Jason never let
her leave the room that upset it's true
it's true it's true well and what's that
that was mostly just me yeah that was
the last shot I had to do for the show
was that was the last shot that was
filmed of Shadowhunters was me walking
away and I was standing there holding
Tom's hand and behind him was Matt and
Harry and Emraan Alberto and David
Castro and Jade and javi and and Steve
Byers and all of these people who have
created our family for so many years
and I just had to turn and walk away but
what's the funny part which is such a
beautiful thing and so personifies what
brusho and our crew was is they came
around the corner and there was our
production manager and producers in 80s
with trays of champagne flutes just
waiting for us to be done not knowing we
were still shooting and kind of caught
their eye had it made me laugh so hard
because I went yes for filming this
beautiful sad moment and you're there
waiting ready to celebrate with all of
us and that's the kind of teamwork that
is a show problematic reader wants to
know about filming that scene with the
mother Jocelyn that scene seeing the two
of you guys back together what was it
like
it was again another moment - that was
so circuitous but it was so nice to have
Maksim back because she was one of the
first actors I shot with on the show and
it's been clary hasn't really had a
mother on the show since she left
because Maris only recently has become
kind of a mother figure to her so she's
been you know she's had Luke being a
father figure but she hasn't really had
that maternal love yeah since her mother
died since finding her mother in that
room with her heart literally out of her
chest and so when clarity turns that
cornered that the last person she
expects to see is her mother and I loved
the way that scene was written just
because it was so jarring and tragic and
that she has this swell of joy seeing
her mother that she never thought she'd
see again and then her mother takes away
the one thing that makes her who she is
and the one reason that she's finally
feels as though she's found her place
not her mom not her mom but her mom is a
messenger yeah her mom is the messenger
but I'm like her mom didn't do it nobody
open it so we need to have a
conversation with the raziel yeah but
that she is the bearer of the bad news
and it's kind of this very weird jarring
moment but it was so beautifully done
and Max and I just had the best time
creating that scene and playing within
it and it was a lovely way it was the
last day shooting in Clara's bedroom as
well so it was a lovely way to say
goodbye to that set yeah and to her in
that relationship and that part of
Clara's life ELISA
Yola wants to know what is your favorite
rune if it's not the angelic rune
because that's something that is obvious
I always loved the shapeshifter rune
mm-hmm it was one of the first rooms
that we created for the show that didn't
exist in the books so it made it a
little special because it was ours yeah
and ultimately somebody told me a long
time ago that you know as an actor
you're a shapeshifter
you change you move you you create new
people and you change who you are in to
fit these molds yeah and that's always
really felt right to me mm-hmm
we're gonna take a couple more fan
questions
dcs wants to know can you tell us who
cried the most on the last day on set me
hi everyone will tell you I was a mess
mostly because I had to cry for the
scenes so and actually the first scene
we shot that day was me walking down the
hallway by myself seeing everything
disappear so I started off my day in
tears and it it became sort of again it
was very cathartic and a very great way
to say goodbye because I was all day
doing all of those scenes in the last
shot I had to cry but I'll never forget
there's a moment we had just wrapped and
we had the wrap party in the soundstage
in the Institute all decorated for the
wedding
we basically had our own Malak wedding
reception after we were done shooting
the Baloch wedding reception
and they kind of let us run amok all
over set but we had the champagne toast
we just said goodbye and we were about
to go change to come back for the party
and I remember stopping at the edge of
the Institute set in my wardrobe and
going if I take one more step that's the
last time I'm gonna be on set as Clary
and I didn't want to move
I turned to I was actually standing next
to Brian the makeup artist and I turned
on I went Brian I don't want to go I
don't want to move I don't want this to
be over
mm-hmm but it was at that point that I
realized that it never really will be
because I looked around at the family
that was there and and now we see the
family that exists with you guys and
with with everything that the show has
created so there isn't really a goodbye
it's just a new beginning yeah we were
getting into so many really great friend
cushions right now um a little Layla
wants to know which I'm curious to know
about this too if you could have had
seen more scenes with any other
character who would it have been oh
there's so many you know who I never got
to work with I never got to work with
chai Hanson oh my god a certain Kyle
yeah I didn't have a single scene with
him I was never on camera with him so I
would have loved to work with him but of
the people I did work with I mean
there's a list of mile long I would have
loved to work with Harry and Isaiah more
I would have loved to work with Jade and
and David caster more I would have loved
to work with Alisha more I would love to
work with Nicola more which I think I
would have because she's my mom
because she's everybody's mom by the way
I have to say I just love that is it
marouk or is it Mara Luke or whatever
Luke and Marus relationship is I think
it's marouk but correct us if we're
wrong but I love I love it amazing
they're so cute and they actually are
everybody's parents in our personal
lives as well just as an FYI
they keep everyone in check everyone's
all taken care of
yeah and there are the people who check
in on us or that we can go to I can't
tell you the number of times I've gone
to either or both of them for advice on
situations I've got to say one of my
favorite scenes of the finale that we
haven't talked about just yet
was seeing Clary and Izzy have the talk
about being each other's parabatai
yeah and I thought it was so incredible
which made it even more gut-wrenching
when you realize that Clarys memories
were gonna be gone and we were not gonna
see that bond come to fruition what was
it like for you to realize that as well
it's very interesting because it's
something they had talked the
showrunners had had teased for us a long
time ago yeah and it would have been
really exciting especially given her
heavenly fire and Clary's angelic light
power just the fact they would have been
such a powerhouse parabatai bond but um
and seeing you know we've seen the how
wonderful that kind of parabatai
relationship and how rich that can be
with Jason Alec and to have Clary and
Izzy grow into that would have been
really beautiful so it is very very sad
that we didn't get to see that but
ultimately as being the storyteller that
I am it's sort of wonderful how it just
played into the the gut-wrenching Ness
of what we got to see you later on we're
gonna start to wrap this up
I spoke with the Shadowhunter
showrunners Todd Darren Darren Darren
and Todd yesterday and I asked them
because all the fans have been dying to
know is this really the end and they had
said this is the end of this permutation
of Shadowhunters that's not to say that
maybe sometime in the future we could do
a reunion special or a movie and and see
these characters a couple years down the
line and do that what are your thoughts
on that idea I'm in where do I sign up
where do I can I yeah I'm there let's do
it honestly at this this family this
show this story is lightning in a bottle
it's a rarefied air and it's family it
always will be you know I learned so
much from every single person on that
set I I grew personally professionally
artistically and any opportunity to
reunite that family and to go back to
this character and the story I'm in save
the word and I'm there I love that we're
gonna end it on one last fan question
because problematic reader came in with
a really great one again who is your
real-life parabatai I feel like the
entire cast yeah like in in my life or
of the cast let's do let's do both in my
life there's I I think I have a pair of
a try because I have two best friends
that I've known since I was probably
nine years old and I don't even have to
speak to them and they know like we we
don't often get to speak because our
lives are so crazy but we keep in touch
as we can and nothing ever changes and
we we're always there for each other and
you know there's those times where you
go you know I need to I need to check in
on seven so and I need to give this
person a call and ultimately there's
always something going on then we're
connected and we always will be and
that's how I feel about the cast too
you know I have a very different
relationship with each one of them and
it that's why I think we get along as
such an amazing family because we're all
so different and each person brings
something from the group but each each
person is also willing to learn and grow
and that's what's created such a
beautiful relationship on and off screen
mm-hmm well as we say goodbye what is
one thing you would like to say that the
Shadowhunters family they've seen the
finale I think the one thing I say this
over and over again is just thank you
you know you existed as a fandom before
the show was even a glimmer in anyone's
eye before any of us were cast and the
fact that you came on this journey with
us and you were open to each one of us
you gave us the warmest welcome and we
became a family but beyond that you
created a community you created a space
for people to feel loved and
accepted and seen and that in and of
itself is a beautiful thing that you
should be proud of that isn't going
anywhere so thank you for letting me be
a small part of that thank you so much
to all of our fans who are watching
right now thank you so much Kat for
coming in and having this conversation
with us you can of course catch Kat on
arrow the season finale is on Monday and
if you tune back in next week I will be
having another chat with Kat about arrow
so stay tuned but thank you so much and
thanks for watching Angels
[Music]
you
you